[Music]
well welcome back everybody I hope you
had a nice Thanksgiving time with your
families and and loved ones
well with turkey and all probably a real
letdown from being around you and me
yeah
good relatives it's tough when you get
used to this kind of rep partay to go
sit with real people do my
sister-in-law's house a bunch of people
I didn't know is that true oh but they
were in show business none of them what
none of them but they had great wealth
yes some of them were it seemed to be
doing just fine but in that Colorado way
nice fleece you're saying they weren't
in show business no and not all of them
were well-to-do nice no some of them
were downright poor oh they don't
understand the struggle I went to the
Isle of celebrity oh really yes we had a
wonderful time I was there with Maude
Adams Dietrich Vader's brother Hans
Justine Bateman Shaquille O'Neal's
lawyer really yes
only the best celebrity Island it's
north of Nova Scotia it's freezing it's
freezing it's on the rocky shoals you
have to get your own food mussels and
clams mussels and clams
[Music]
you